by its very nature police work can put
officers in the middle of highly charged
situations that sometimes run the risk
of escalating into violence
now one department is looking to better
train its officers to keep such
confrontations from getting out of
control from Milwaukee Dean Reynolds as
the story put me in handcuffs the same
goes on all the time all the time this
is what police trainees in Milwaukee
practice as they prepare for what could
be the fight of their lives so at the
end it turned out he was a victim crash
can you cut the victim yes okay and why
exactly addressing bias and dealing with
communities always sensitive to it is a
consequence of many highly charged
confrontations that have forced officers
into court be careful not to get sucked
into what they're calling about listen
to the approach of police trainer
Rondon Powell if a person that live in
the neighborhood called in saying
there's a black person sitting in the
car outside my house are you gonna be
sucked into this person bias yes ma'am
black people come in the communities
where we're not maleic people live sorry
you going to stop every first thing you
know it's opposite of what that
community different bathroom looks like
be aware of your biases but also be
aware that part of the employment here
is to investigate things that I grew up
in the neighborhood in the inner city of
Milwaukee's were police and community
relations was not good at all and I
found out that there's certain things
that I view when I was a kid that really
wasn't true and as I became more of an
experienced police officer I began to
obtain a desire to come to the Academy
and teach recruits bias-based actions
really impact the community and your
department I think in the last five
years what we've seen is a great deal
more attention being paid to what's
called de-escalation skills Milwaukee
Police Chief Edward Flynn it would
always work but we do want to give them
those skills that they have time to
employ it we do our very very best not
to fight with people we don't want to go
hands-on Stacey Steen has been
instructing recruits here for five years
I
we want as police officers to gain your
cooperation through words believe these
recruits have to pass state tests
covering more than a thousand hours of
training cop work your way down there is
no other occupation in government none
including the military that puts so much
responsibility on the shoulders of the
lowest ranking member of the
organization
Angela clinker and Lorenzo mahomes are
two of those recruits why are you doing
this now well because I live here in
Milwaukee and I plan on living here
throughout the rest of my life though
why wouldn't I want to be in the
forefront of doing something good for
the city did he come in through this
door or through that door if you come
into contact with somebody in your treat
them with respect and you know you treat
them like you'd want to be treated I
think that can go a long way towards
kind of building trust between the
community and the police department and
as these recruits cross the stage to
being officers one final reminder from
their chief no matter how many
scenario-based training you do how many
how many skill sets you do soon earlier
they are applying this in a dynamic
stressful ambiguous set of circumstances
and that's the true test
and that's when character takes over
or CBS this morning Saturday Dean
Reynolds Milwaukee so interesting what
they're doing there those that first
moment when you come in contact those
are really critical moments that's when
a lot happens that can set it on one
course or another know precisely